americans reeling from sky high prices
got some good news this week the
government's latest inflation report
showed prices came down for used cars
and trucks apparel and especially
airline tickets chris vancleave is at
raleigh durham international airport
chris good morning so what's behind this
fall and the cost of flights
well good morning airline fares dropped
about eight percent in july could be
another sign that the worst of inflation
is behind us this came as airlines got a
break from soaring fuel costs and they
saw that peak summer demand edge off a
little bit bottom line this could mean a
deal for you if you're trying to squeeze
in one more trip how does san diego
sound on average now trending about 230
dollars cheaper
than its peak in may hawaii down 154
bucks even flights to as far away as
prague could cost you about 300 less and
according to the travel site hopper
round-trip domestic tickets for
september and october are down roughly
37 percent from may but hopper expects
airfares to start to climb by the second
week in october as people book for the
holidays so best bets for finding a deal
book early and be flexible with your
dates and times even think about nearby
surrounding airports sometimes you can
save hundreds just by flying out of a
different airport name
get them while they're hot go ahead and
book those fights chris thank you